you will hear the term production
function thrown around in economic
circles and it might seem a little
intimidating and a little mathy at first
but as you're about to see it's a fairly
basic idea it's this idea that you could
have these various inputs let's call
this input number
one and then you have input number two
and you can keep going and then you put
them in their inputs into some type of
process and then that function
let's just call that f that's going to
describe how much output you can get
given
that input we can also describe it a
little bit more mathematically those of
you who remember your algebra 2 might
recognize this where we could say the
output it's often used the letter q
in economic circle it's going to be a
function it's going to be a function of
the various inputs so i'll put input
number one
input
number two and you could go you could
have as many inputs as is necessary to
produce that good
and these inputs if you wanted to
categorize them these are the classic
factors of production that we would have
talked about before these would be
these would be your land
labor
capital
and entrepreneurship
and it doesn't have to be all of them
but each of these inputs would likely be
factored as one of these now this might
still seem very abstract and very mathy
so to make things very tangible let's
let's give it let's give a tangible
example let's say that we're trying to
make a
a bread toasting operation so what we
need to do is we take bread we stick it
in a toaster and then once it's toast
we're done and so what are our inputs
there
well you're definitely going to need
some bread
so let me draw some bread right over
here my best attempt at drawing bread so
that right over there
that is bread you could call that input
number one
now you're also going to need a toaster
at least one toaster or toasters i
should say and let's say the toasters
that we use for this operation
they can toast four pieces of bread at a
time
and it takes ten minutes to do that four
slices
in
ten
minutes
now you might say well aren't those
going to be all of our inputs but then
the obvious question is that bread isn't
just going to jump into the toaster on
its own and then jump back out someone
there's going to be needs to be some
labor to operate this operation
so we're going to need
some toaster operators and let's say
that they can
they can process
they can process
one slice per minute one
slice
per minute i know many of you are
thinking that you could do better than
that but try to do it all day one slice
per minute now based on this if these
are really all of the three inputs into
producing the output posted piece of
bread we could try to construct a
production function here so let's do
that
so let's say the output is going to be
the number of slices
slices
of
toasted
toasted bread
and it's going to be equal to and i'm
going to write this as well i'm going to
make our production function as being
the minimum of of several values and
we're going to see it's going to be
based on what's going to be our rate
limiting factor and i don't want to get
too much in the weeds with you on this
but just to help us understand so it's
going to be the minimum
of
well the amount of bread you have so
slices of bread
slices
of bread
and why does that make sense well your
only the amount of toasted bread you can
produce is always going to be limited by
the amount of untoasted bread that you
put into your process if you only have
60 that's going in per hour here well
then you can only produce a maximum of
60 right over here and this is going to
be per hour
per
hour
so this is going to be the slices of
bread
per
hour
now our other input
how much toast can one toaster
toast
in one hour well if they do four slices
in 10 minutes we'll multiply that times
six to get to an hour that's going to be
24 slices per hour so we can do
24
times the number of toasters
times the
toasters
and then last but not least
how much bread or how many slices can
one person process
per hour well it's going to be 60 slices
per hour so we do 60
times
times let's call them workers i was
going to call them toasters but we are
using that for the equipment
times the number of workers
and so
it's worth at this point just pause this
video and really process what's going on
what are the inputs here and what are
the outputs
well the inputs are right over here the
number of slices of bread per hour the
number of toasters we have at our
disposal the number of workers
toasters you could view as capital
workers you could view as labor
and now another interesting thing to
think about and we will talk a lot about
this in economics is what's going on in
the long run and the short run and
production functions are useful for
thinking about the long run and the
short run because the short run is
defined the short
run
is defined as the situation in which at
least one of your inputs is fixed let me
write this down at least
at least
one
input
is
fixed
now what does that mean in our bread
toasting example right over here well
let's just say that we can it's very
easy to get slices of bread if we if we
have the capacity and we want to produce
more
bread the slices of bread are let's say
it's just never our rate limiting factor
so that part isn't fixed
but to get a new toaster let's say these
are special toasters and you got to
order them and it takes a month
so let's say that there's a one month
lead time on this input one
month
lead
time
and let's say
for workers there's just not a line of
people ready to toast toast you have to
put a job posting out there and you're
going to have to interview people and so
let's say that it takes
two weeks to hire someone
so two weeks
to
hire
or i guess you could also say two weeks
to hire or to fire someone if you want
to reduce capacity let's say it takes
one month to either get a toaster or to
remove a toaster
well in that case the short run in this
situation is a time period where at
least one of the inputs is fixed so
pause this video and think about what
would be the short run in our situation
well the short run in our situation the
number of toasters we're going to have
is going to be fixed for at least a
month so our short run in this situation
is up to a month
so up to
up to a month
and then the other side of it what would
the long run be
well in the long run by definition none
of your inputs are fixed you can change
the number you have of any of these
things so our long run is going to be
greater than one month
in this example now it's really worth
noting that was just for this example if
we were talking about some type of
automobile factory and the output is the
number of automobiles produced per day
or per month and then you have all these
inputs you would have your metal you
would have your labor and then you would
have the equipment for the factory
itself
well there the long run it might take a
another year or even two years or five
years to build a factory in that case
the long run would be the time period
greater than it amount it takes to build
another factory usually capital
is the thing that is most fixed for the
longest period of time and that's why i
made it hard for us to get our toasters
so i will leave you there this is just
an introduction to the idea of a
production function but hopefully with
our bread toasting example it is not so
intimidating